what you got here nick uh british
related name game
brynden i hope you're both well i've got
my mask on as you can see this will
definitely stop me from getting
coronavirus anyway i have a
uk themed name game for you and that is
british comedians
well ricky gervais would be number one
right okay
eddie izzard would be number two
and here we are it's okay
it's hard no who's my god
russell howard nice wow
russell brand does he count he's done
stand up
yeah that's a good call i'll give you
that is russell howard a real person
yeah he's big
oh wow i gotta check him out i'm gonna
go with
um oh you got this how about um
a british comedian that's enjoyable
or non-enjoyable would be a
good man like um
how about come on
also known as who's the guy always in a
suit
jimmy carr jimmy carr i was gonna say
jimmy carr yeah i took a picture with
him he's my mom's favorite jimmy car's a
legend he's a legend
very sweet man to say also that
uh who was the guy that died up in
canada
of cocaine the mayor of toronto
rob ford
i don't think so you know rob ford came
to the comedy store one night really
yeah not shocked one of the greatest
things ever but rob four
definitely and then i'm gonna go up on a
limb and say um
i'm trying to think of some of the guys
i even worked over there yeah
that guy right there dude oh wow rob
ford bro who looks like prince harry if
he really fell off man
prince hardly looks like tim dillon's
uncle
you guys know about benny hill benny
hill the preacher
no that's benny hen that's been him
a better name game would have been um
british bands
let's do it dude we it's this just shows
what we know about our forefathers dude
that's tough
jack [ __ ] and jack shore
are the two things we know about her i
can't believe i found that jimmy carr
jimmy car was great it's a good choice
he's so cool oh there's also a girl
there's a girl katie um
nida no kate
moss no is she british kate moss is huh
there you go what if just anything
british do we even know
basically any uh daily show
correspondent i feel like they were all
british comedians
did we say ricky gervais yeah oh mr bean
uh charlie chaplin was british yep
i think uh who's uh the guy who had the
late night talk show from scotland craig
kilburn
ferguson craig kilburn was espn and also
had a late night show
yes that's right um there's a comedian
named soju who's a comedian
um there is a oh who's this comedian i
just worked with
over there we don't know a lot of
british comedians
my brain is just that's what happens
when you get too specific
yep yeah well but thank you britain
for letting us leave and choose one of
the 70 hot girls apparently over there
as well
oh i know it's a couple people though
bexie he's a rapper over there
um alex bowen um
i'm just naming british people winston
churchill i've said him twice now you
know
okay he's good though don churchill his
brother
little don little dog speaking of
british
oh yeah idris elba also
also corona alumni
with the show-and-tell bro dude have you
seen me have you seen the wire
the tv show the wire yeah man i'm
american yeah sorry about it
he does a really good uh english accent
like
american oh yeah yeah in that show i
just started watching it so oh yeah
oh the wire mm-hmm um it's a great show
well [ __ ] man i gotta open it you know
the office was original
english show oh i have to see i haven't
even seen that version yet nope supposed
to be the best version man i'm just
feeling bad i'm just feeling like i
gotta have seven donations simon cowell
yeah you know uh american idol
originated in england
i haven't done anything for our
forefathers man dude it's crazy that
this whole thing was your idea
[Music]
too